we know that quadrilateral abcd over
here is a parallelogram and what i want
to discuss in this video is a general
way of finding the area of a
parallelogram in the last video we
talked about a particular way of finding
a
the area of a rhombus you can take half
the product of its diagonals and a
rhombus is a parallelogram but you can't
just generally take the the product of
the half the product of the diagonals of
any parallelogram it has to be a rhombus
so now we're just going to talk about
parallelograms
so what do we know about parallelograms
well we know the opposite sides are
parallel
so that that side is parallel to that
side and this side is parallel to this
side and we also know that opposite
sides are congruent so this length is
equal to this length and
this length is equal to this length over
here
now if we draw a diagonal i'll draw a
diagonal a c
we can split our parallelogram into two
triangles and we've proven this multiple
times that these two triangles are
congruent but we can do it pretty in a
pretty straightforward way we can look
obviously a d is equal to bc we have dc
is equal to a b and then both of these
triangles share this third side right
over here they both share they both
share ac so we can say triangle let me
write this in yellow we could say
triangle adc
a dc is congruent to triangle let me get
this right so it's going to be congruent
to triangle it says it a d c so i went
along this double magenta slash first
then the pink and then and then and then
i went d
and then i went the last one
so i'm going to say c b a
because i want the double magenta then
pink then the last one so c b a triangle
c
b a and this is by side side side
congruency all three sides they have
three corresponding sides that are
congruent to each other so the triangles
are congruent to each other and what
that tells us is that the areas of these
two triangles are going to be the same
so if i want to find the area
the area of a b c d the whole
parallelogram is going to be the equal
to the area of triangle let me just
write it here it's equal to the area of
a
d c
plus the area of c cba
but the area of cba is just the same
thing as the area of adc
because they are congruent by side side
side so this is just going to be 2 times
the area of triangle adc which is
convenient for us because we know how to
find the areas of triangles the area of
triangles is literally just one-half
times base times height so it's one-half
times base times height of this triangle
and we are given the base of adc it is
this length right over here it is dc you
could view it as the base of the entire
parallelogram and if we wanted to figure
out the height we could draw an altitude
down like this
so this
this is perpendicular we could call that
the height right over there so if you
want the total area if you want the
total area of parallelogram a b c d
it is equal to two times one half times
base times height well two times one
half is just one and so you're just left
with base times height so we could call
this b so it's just b
b
times this height over here base times
height so that's a neat result and it's
kind of you might have guessed this
would be the case but if you want to
find the area of any parallelogram and
if you can figure out the height it is
literally you just take one of the bases
because both bases are going to be the
opposite sides are equal so it could
have been either that side or that side
times the height so that's one way you
could have found the area or you could
have multiplied the other way to think
about it is you could have multiplied so
if i were to turn this parallelogram
over it would look something like this
it would look something like this
so if i were to rotate it
if i were to rotate it like that and
stand it on this side so this would be
point let me draw the points this would
be point a
let me make sure i'm doing this right
yep this would be point a this would be
point d this would be point c and then
this would be point b
you could also do it this way you could
say it's one sorry not one half that
would be for a triangle it would be the
area of this would be base times height
so you could say it's h times d c
so you could say this is going to be
equal to h
times the length dc times dc that's one
way to do it that's this base times this
height or you could say
or you could say it's equal to ad it's
equal to
ad
times
i'll call this
i'll call this altitude right here i'll
call this height 2
times
h2 maybe i'll call this h1
h1 h2 so you could take this base times
this height or you could take this base
times
times this height right over here this
is h2 either way so someone were to give
you a parallelogram just to make things
clear
you know obviously you'd have to be some
way to be able to figure out the height
so someone would give you a
parallelogram like this they were to
tell you this is a parallelogram if they
were to tell you that this length right
over here is 5 and if they were to tell
you that this distance
this distance is six then the area of
this parallelogram would literally be
five times six i drew the altitude
outside of the parallelogram i could
have drawn it right over here as well
that would also be six so the area of
this parallelogram would be
would be 30.